the Joe Rogan experience and I think
this is experimenting self-government
which is a completely new thing in human
history that's redefined the way the
rest of the world governs itself I mean
this that's what America really is is it
perfect [ __ ] no but humans aren't
perfect there's not a goddamn human
anywhere that's perfect there's not a
single culture anywhere that doesn't
have something that's inherently wrong
with it it's the best system for
imperfect human beings yes right and
it's it's a system based on the the fact
the the unavoidable fact that we are
imperfect yeah okay and that and that
you cannot you cannot constrain
mankind's nature to the extent that
progressives would like to there's
there's a belief from innocence from
just marxist ideology and kind of french
revolution thought that you can perfect
human nature that you can get people to
be perfect eventually if you just give
the state enough control and and and and
stop certain thoughts that are bad keep
those down keep these elevate these
other ones you can eventually get us to
where we think we should be I think
that's utopian I don't see how that's
ever possible and I think our US
constitutional system understands that
you know it's not it's not like the
founders got together and just made a
bunch of stuff up right they were they
were they're very well versed in history
they do studies it relentlessly and they
took ideas from Jerusalem and Athens and
Rome in London they took all these best
ideas and these best practices and they
said this is probably how we should
govern we're first gonna say why
government exists okay we're gonna say
that in the Declaration of Independence
when John Thomas Jefferson wrote that
the Declaration of Independence was
wasn't just declaring its independence
it was also declaring why government
exists and it exists to protect the
naeli noble rights life liberty and
pursuit of happiness or he gets these
ideas from guys like John Locke is that
life liberty and property or those are
unalienable rights and you protect
rights you can't give them to people but
you can protect them because they're
already inherent in you they're natural
rights okay then the Constitution told
us how to govern so think how do we live
together well there should be checks and
balances you should have an emphasis on
local state control because the problems
are closest to the people and they
should be closest to the representatives
down at that level 51% of the population
shouldn't be able to tell the other 49%
what to do
you know we should have an electoral
college so that the biggest population
centers can't tell everybody else what
to do there's important structures like
embedded in the Constitution that have
allowed us to actually last I think as
long as we have we have the oldest
political die it's the oldest document
the world it's the oldest Constitution
the also were the youngest one of the
youngest countries but we're the only
ones that had such a long standing
Constitution I think that's important to
realize too it's very bizarre that they
had the insight to realize that [ __ ]
could go so sideways that they put all
these checks and balances together that
actually can reasonably well in a
reasonably well way work today yeah I
mean there's a lot of people that
disagree with a lot of the aspects of it
one person one vote they would like that
they don't think that representative
democracy is important now because we
have this ability to communicate that we
didn't have in the 1800s you know you
had to send a [ __ ] Pony with a letter
on it in order to get your word across
now you can actually tweet and you could
vote online if we so deem it and we've
made it legal but the electoral college
do you feel like that that in especially
with like things like super-delegates do
you think that that's still the way to
do things and he's still an effective
way to yeah why is that because the the
alternative is the 51 percent versus the
49 percent and that what that really
boils down to is New York and and and
and Los Angeles telling everybody who
the president should be but the vast
majority people don't live in New York
and Los Angeles that's exactly the
problem 20 million and 7 what is it 9
million or something in New York on
Tuesday but and that's the issue right
because he you really are you're you're
and when people congregate in population
centers they also tend to start to think
alike and I just think and on a more
fundamental level look at the difference
between Democrats and Republicans people
wonder what that difference is and
there's a lot of differences of course
but a really kind of simple heuristic to
think about it is the word Democrat and
Republican okay one believes in appear
democracy one believes in a republic I
was saying Democrats believe in total
pure democracy but but when you're
saying abolish the Electoral College you
are saying pure democracy you're saying
51% of the population can tell the other
49% what to do the Electoral College is
a is a check and balance against that
that gives those states in the middle
some kind of voice that they wouldn't
have otherwise had it makes them why is
everybody in Iowa right now do you think
they'd be in Iowa if if if we didn't
have electoral college could deer
hunting there yeah that's a good reason
to go but like but but the reality is is
they would only they would only be
campaigning in the big population
centers they wouldn't bother going to
the rural areas because you're gonna get
the most bang for your buck going to
just the population here meaning
physically campaigning physically and
also but also who you're accountable to
so that's the most important thing who
are you accountable to your I'm gonna
care if you're accountable to the rural
areas like you should be into the middle
of the country like you should be
because if you only care about 51% of
the vote you're just going to go to
those main population centers and you're
only going to talk to them you're only
gonna care what they think I don't think
that's good it's not a good that's not
good for democracy especially when we
have such a wide diversity of
preferences and and just styles of
living across the country still that
important to be physically in a place to
campaign it's like to physically go to
Chicago to Camp Lee and physically go to
Iowa yeah people I think people want to
see you you know it was a good argument
to be made that Hillary Clinton lost
because she just didn't go to Wisconsin
these last days so I think people's
people want to get to know you people
want to see you well the good argument
of Hillary too is she people didn't
believe she had enough energy to go and
campaign and I don't know I never met
her I can't I can't tell you what the
inside look at that campaign was its I
just know it didn't work